should access to assisted suicide be
made easier in Germany Minister
theologian and husband Nicolaos NIDA has
addressed this question he's our guest
this week welcome to the show become
good morning at civic welcome to all you
viewers as well this is the DW interview
and I'm Alexandra phenomen it's nice mr.
Schneider last year your wife was
diagnosed with cancer you gave up your
post as the chairman of germany's
protestant church council to support her
how is she doing now he does ever fall
Horton of kiddie r f oily good if she is
doing quite well we had adjusted
ourselves to the idea that we only had a
few more months left together but now
it's turned out that it'll probably be a
few years the treatments were very
successful so we hope that we'll have a
few years of real peace to still enjoy
the time we have together underneath
okay one of the last month's been like
for you the gang when one up there go
other filming fathers really emotionally
it was a real rollercoaster ride first
there was a huge shock thought and
cautious hope Oh at the moment I'm doing
really well and I'm very very thankful
for the gift of time and wonderful
togetherness and my wife and I are still
able to have mastaba did you have
moments of genuine despair when you
didn't know what to do other foots wife
you would be exaggerating to say despair
in the sense of not knowing up from down
I've always been occupied with the issue
of death and dying as a minister who
performs burials you're busy with it all
the time and with the knowledge that
were mortal via and my wife and I are
both people who this concept of life
goes beyond death it would improve 20
feet we believe that we will partake of
the resurrection and that after death
our life doesn't just end I'm fun to
induce instead our time on earth is up
with you we also believe in a continued
existence in the presence of the lord
and we're counting on seeing each other
again
but time on earth is just beautiful and
it would soon be over really got me down
but you couldn't call it a deep
depression either differed through it
was something like a huge sadness oh my
god but still coupled with the effort to
do something about it does blue moon I
wanted to be there for my wife fully to
do what I can and provide support so
that she at least can now beat the
cancer community creeps belief
expression you're talking about it very
openly after the diagnosis you and your
wife were also very open about it in
interviews why other design of our one
thing I didn't want speculation and
rumors about why I was stepping down so
there was only one thing to do and that
was to tell the truth he finds you I
thought well that's always the best the
second thing is that the issue of death
and dying occupies everyone for
different reasons there are many people
in our situation and providing a bit of
public reflection to stimulate other's
thoughts and provide information was
what we were trying to do Oh under I'm
just routine by the beep that's why I
ones of the moon the reaction we got
shows it work you become a hobbit site
oh that's the soft luminous we've gained
contact too many people in similar
situations and who were very happy that
we actually expressed a few things that
they were also feeling whether it was
being emotional disappointment grief or
rage to their co hopes and expectations
as well 2-10 off moment swagga know you
spoke very openly about a company and
your wife if she wished to take around
life even though you yourself reject
assisted suicide could you explain that
place if up lean and consume it as a
clam yeah the sign is I want to die at
the hand of God and for me that doesn't
mean me actively shortening my life this
is something other than the issue of
medical life-prolonging measures
when my life is coming to an end then
medical mean should not be used to keep
me alive artificially other than my lead
I support that immediately and I have
set it out in a living will therefore
beneath you does this also get cleared
my wife's gone a step further guys
goodbye though she says and also based
on theological reasoning that God has
given her responsibility for her life
and for herself and when she can stand
it no longer then she wants to end her
own life in that she kills herself beba
I'll say about tooted I will always
reject this step for myself and believe
for theological reasons as well if that
it's wrong we've been arguing about this
for 10 years or even much longer called
lemon oh but my wife remains my wife
even when she has a different opinion on
this issue by the way she differs from
me on a few issues but that's actually
made our marriage and our love stronger
we've learned to remain together even
though we've got differences in opinion
and we respect and love each other so at
this point it was completely clear that
I wouldn't leave my wife alone and my
wife knows just how far she can push me
oh not really i would hold her hand and
accompany her if things should ever go
that far because she's still my wife
even though her positions differ from
mine like mind of coal oh because I'm
opposite to your mother no active
assisted suicide is illegal in Germany
yet suicide and being an accessory
aren't usually prosecuted now the German
Bundestag wants to establish new
legislation for assisted suicide what
should the new law contain you think and
I think such a law is actually only
necessary to safeguard doctors who are
providing treatment what doctors can and
can't do has to be clear the way I
understand it the vehicle profession is
there to maintain and preserve life to
promote and protect it not at any price
but that must be the basic idea should
need
killing should not be the job of the
medical profession to students going to
need of gaba and the same goes for the
state what kind of support can a person
expect from the state if you ask whether
the state should organize whether people
should be killed or not well I think
here to the state shouldn't do it human
me Oh effluent ethnic their studies the
estate is so powerful and so strong and
we had our experience in the Nazi period
was killing programs and criminal
programs coming to start through the
activities of the states and it wasn't
just the Nazis as is always said
millions were killed mcgann because I it
was the action of the German state
criminally murdered millions of people
and in view of all these experiences
government activities should be focused
on maintaining and promoting life CEO of
consent even the Swiss liebe vodka
product it it's something completely
different if in an individual case a
person cannot go on living death Keith
that happens and that's why the state
should not be able to compel people to
remain alive either that's movement
awesome and ahead you have to separate
those things and we cannot force anybody
to go on living no matter what instead
we have to accept that an individual no
longer wants to live and here I think we
have the opportunity to let him go his
own way and he can be advised as to how
to do it without doctors or the
government getting into the act of
killing the Lutz's agua que el todo
Scotty if he wants to do it in the end
we have to respect that listen via death
I'm in the respect even the church has
been striving for thousands of years to
do away with suicide barbaric means were
used and as churches we've dispensed
with that and we don't do it anymore now
when a person can no longer go on what
is called for is support I'm
understanding and love no not big light
115 but not that we force him to live a
beneath the fittings its length rule
even swinging
professional that means when some
members of parliament demand as is now
the case the doctors operating under
strict constraints should be allowed to
assist patients in killing themselves
they're going too far in your opinion
yeah let's get in for life defeat me
that goes too far for me if they take
action but not in the sense of giving
advice but most people in Germany want
and have spoken out in favor of making
access to assisted suicide simpler you
could even say that in a democratic
country that should be the deciding
factor yardas couldn't a month yes you
could see it that way I'd answer that
the representatives are morally free and
able to decide according to their
ethical values rather than simply
amplifying what the population is
demanding a classic example of that is
the death penalty thought of you surveys
are always coming in to say that a
majority is in favor of the death
penalty argue but we don't have the
death penalty and don't have it for good
reasons it's on the same level as what I
just said state actions should protect
maintain and promote life and not killed
what gets precisely on this level the
MPs have made a commitment to principles
and I think that is part of the
Democratic consensus as well being we
elect representatives who simply amplify
the results of opinion polls and
representatives and personalities who
are guided by their moral compasses not
when making every single decision opko
all netted a meat person d chitin I was
yoga business Wyndemere holes but when
it comes to basic ethical questions only
when it's about life and death when it's
about that then people sticking to their
principles is completely consistent with
democracy autocom I mr. McCartan
conceived under myth Germany's churches
reject assisted suicide but aren't they
abandoning people to their fates align
nine baby no because Germany's churches
are also saying we have understanding
for people in hopeless situations we
know there are people who can no longer
go on living we know that it's a reality
of life and we can
offer these people support we may not
judge them or isolate them instead we
must help them and lovingly stand by
them fun indeed miss behavin would be
leader by state you've experienced it
yourself how is it when you're faced
with a moral dilemma of what would you
advise people who find themselves in a
similar situation I tell them to listen
to their conscience and read the first
book of Corinthians chapter 13 verse 13
and now abide faith home alive these
three but the greatest of these is love
the boys don't they so if we always end
the DW interview by having our guest
complete three sentences could you
please complete these three for us the
current debate about assisted suicide in
Germany go thought gives us a great
opportunity to ponder over the finite
aspect of life and do a great deal to
enable people to die with dignity in our
country I'm to me dying with dignity
means I'm still for me dying with
dignity means to die free of pain and
not alone that's why I feel especially
alive when been humid mine with my wife
and grandchildren and can enjoy life
Thank You mr. Schneider you're welcome